a retired man absolutely true or retired
man recently noticed that someone had
been tidying up his work shed during the
night that's right he had no idea who it
was so he put a security camera in the
shed and learned it was a mouse I am not
kidding about this yes every night the
mouse would pick up loose little screws
and other items left out by the guy and
then just carry them and put them back
in the man's toolbox
he's got footage of it he released the
footage here's the footage it's really
sweet you can see the mouse picking up
stuff and putting it into the tool box
yes because this all night long it's
absolutely unbelievable it's really cool
yeah
so I was very impressed by this Mouse's
generosity and helpfulness so impressed
in fact that I hired the mouse to help
out around our studio give him a job
yeah
pay the mouse for what it does best just
helping out and he's been great take a
look for example he is working as a
cameraman on the show he's been doing an
amazing job yeah he's helping with hopes
out with cue cards yeah very good with
two cards in the control room he works
as the technical director on the show
when Howie Mandel's booked he disinfects
his dressing room
yeah he he plays cards with crew members
on Union breaks and he's yeah he
decorates the cake for a staff members
birthday which is very nice
yes filled with disease doings does my
hair just support the show yeah and yet
deleting negative comments from our
shows Facebook page and finally
preparing Andy's pre-show coffee thank
you very much yeah okay that that
segment of our show is for little
children that's right tell little kids
that I drink yeah they already know